Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on guys.
This is Rob and we are picking back up with the events of swords of X.
And in this video we are covering the hellion.
So we'll be initially pick up here with the resurrection of empath of Robert
Della Roshe. I think it is I'm sorry, manual. Dayla Roshe.
I'm not a hundred percent sure how to pronounce that name,
but this guy impath is, is not like the most powerful, but he's pretty powerful,
right? As his name suggests he can basically read,
manipulate the emotions of other people. He can also control emotions,
but he can only do it one emotion at a time, right?
So he can make you feel love or hate or anger or something like that.
So he's a pretty good asset to have on your team.
The funny thing about this though, is that with the hellions team itself,
and this is something to kind of point out here.
The thing about the hellions team is these are kind of like castoffs to a degree
originally, the hellions where the team of Emma Frost,
it was almost like Emma Frost, new mutants team.
They kind of went against the X-Men and new mutants and so on and so forth.
They were on again off again, enemies. And they actually,
they teamed up on some of some occasions.
But the overall idea here is that they're largely led by Mr. Sinister and the
way this kind of plays out is it talks about what move is going to come next,
right?
That the contest of swords is one where it may very well be the X-Men will lose,
right. Or even if they win, they could lose some of their kind.
And it's one of the most important things to remember here that the X-Men are
all about maintaining their existing population, right?
Like making sure they don't lose mutant lives,
even if it does involve some massive conflict that's going on. Right.
And so the idea here is to see if there's a see if it's possible to kind of find
a way to basically win without winning. Now, this is kind of Jonathan Hickman,
although he's not really the one writing this story or at least not directly,
but this is one of those things where,
where I guess really Zeb Wells has kind of taken a page out of Jonathan Hickman,
but it's based on the idea of, of like Avengers, new Avengers.
If you guys recall when Valeria was talking to Reed, as she said, you can't win.
Now it's time to find a way to not lose. That's basically,
what's kind of going on here. And sinister is the one who chimes in and says,
well, what if we sabotage them?
What if we let my hellions do what they do best right.
Light sheet steel until a Rocco, like older swords, the weapons belong to us.
Right? And so the idea is that the hellions are going to go into other world and
basically either steal the swords of the,
of those individuals who were already there or find some way to sabotage them.
Now, this is hugely against the rules, right? It's massively against the rules.
And if they get caught, there would be hell to pay.
But the funny thing about this is Xander and Magneto kinda mull this over for a
second and say, yeah, but it might be kind of worth it, right?
Like it's worth the risk. If we can save the lives of mutants,
especially younger, Munes right. If we can save the lives of these individuals,
these, these people who have to fight and not have to fight at all.
And so the funny thing about this is that initially the stance of people like
Exodus and a few people here and there is, we shouldn't do this,
but when it's put to a vote, five people vote in favor of it,
which means it passes. And so from there, the response of Exodus is okay, fine.
If that's it, that's how it's going to be.
The hellions will March into a Rocco to end this tournament before it starts.
And the fearless leader, Mr. Sinister will lead the way.
And that's what a sinister is like, what, wait a minute, what now, now,
wait a minute. Now I didn't say I was going to go on this mission. Right.
And it's kind of like, no, but I mean, they're your team.
You should be the one to lead them.
So how many people think this sinister should lead this campaign?
And only four people vote. Right? So sinister, you know, it's,
it's not really a passing motion. Sinister is kind of allowed to stay,
but then he kind of gets back into everything going on. Right.
He basically says like, you know, I want to have like on my team,
I do not want him hanging around with Polaris. Right.
We saw how fast he just kind of gala vented into other worlds. And he ended up,
you know, barely escaping by the skin of his teeth. I'm sorry, Magneto.
But like your daughter is bad news. It Magneto is like, you know what?
I changed my vote. I vote for Senator to go.
And so it was like sinister now has to go, right? Nathaniel, Essex,
Renzo's mouth. And now he has to go on this mission from there,
we switch over directly to the team itself.
And there are a couple of characters here that I want to kind of talk about for
a second. Orphan maker is an interesting character in and of himself, right?
His name is, is for the most part, Peter, we don't really know a ton about him.
And we don't even know a whole lot about his powers. We know that like he can,
he has a kind of mechanized suit, but that's really,
it he's a character that hasn't really been fully fleshed out over the years.
The funny thing about this is that it is one of these instances where it's kind
of a shame, right? Like orphan maker appeared back in 1988.
And aside from him having kind of been like a cohort of nanny and you know,
her basically saving him from being killed by sinister because sinister couldn't
control him, he's fought the he's fought the, the x-ray's fund.
X-Factor I think he fought the Avengers at one point.
Marvel just never really did anything with him. So the fact that he's here,
I think it's kind of a reflection of his status in the overall X-Men comics.
And he's almost kind of like an onion sellable character nanny has a far more
significant history, even if it's only on a small scale,
probably one of Andrew's biggest moments came when she D H storm was,
she turned storm into a little girl and that's when the storm first met gambit.
Right. So it was kind of during Chris Claremont's era,
but then of course you guys know Psylocke. You guys also are aware of havoc.
The character of wild child is a little more, um,
I would say obscure to the average come up,
a greeter wild child appeared back in 1983. I think it was. Um,
and he was a character who, well, he originally appeared in alpha flight,
but he was a character named Kyle Gibson who was based largely off Wolverine and
saber tooth. And it was part of that era whereby no,
because what we're going to say,
Richard was so popular that Marvel was kind of finding ways to basically create
characters that would make them intriguing out with John Byrne, right.
In the title. Right.
It was kind of like let's create like a Wolverine type character.
And even within like his origin story, it's still very similar. Right?
So a very similar to it, to Wolverines in the sense that Cal given,
he was basically a kid whose powers manifested.
He was essentially kicked out of the home by his parents.
He wondered the street, he was ultimately taken in by gamma flight.
He ended up being taken in and experimented on by the original secret empire,
kind of an offshoot of Hydra. He eventually became like weapon Omega. And then,
you know, there was the whole of a new X factor. So,
but he's one of these characters where you don't really, I mean,
if you read the old comics, wild child had a pretty interesting run,
especially in the early 1990s when it was like super high octane,
fast paced stories. Um, in 2009, or I think it was 2006, 2009,
he died during the Wolverine's origin story arc.
And then basically brought back as part of Coca-Cola.
But from there you also have gray Crow and gray Crow is a long-standing
character because he was originally part of the original marauders, right.
There were led by an eventual Essex during the massacre.
He has the ability to basically tap into technology.
So it's kind of a hodgepodge ragtag gang here, right? I mean, these are,
this is not by any means kind of an organized team. I mean, it is, but it's,
it's just kind of characters who were there that nobody could really do anything
with, or couldn't really control or whose appearances whose powers made them,
you know, unable to kind of function in the normal world.
But the idea behind this is that sinister initially brought back a version of
himself and then essentially kind of thought them out with the intention of
sending that version of himself out on a mission instead of, of sinister prime,
so to speak going himself.
And then this version that he thought I'd actually rebels. And it was like, no,
I don't.
So they actually kind of end up in Vogue.
A game of rock paper scissors in order to decide who it is that's going to go
out there. And it turns out that the main Sentencer was the one who lost.
So he has to go on this mission. Now, once they enter into a, into,
to what's basically Avalon, this led by Jamie Bradick.
If you guys recall our video on Excalibur, that that story arc that we did,
this guy is powerful. He's a reality. Warper, he's also kind of crazy.
And he's basically ranting and raving at this guy.
Newford who supposedly had told Jamie that he knows that he's familiar with
horses and that, uh,
he's an equestrian and that they kind of brought this horse in for the purpose
of, of, you know, training it,
breaking it in to the Jimmy Braddock could enjoy it.
And it turns out Mueller never said any such thing by me for never claimed that
he never said that,
but you kind of have sinister and Jimmy Braddock sort of hanging out, right.
You're kind of, kind of talking to each other,
but this is something that's kind of interesting to me because it's a little bit
of humor and what's otherwise a pretty interesting story arc. Right. And I,
and I, I kind of love this to be honest,
it's one of the good things about extra sorts.
An ex of sorts does a really good job of maintaining the tone of the existing
comics while also giving us an ongoing story. And I kind of have to say,
I think that's something that Marvel has been lacking in recent years, right?
That you have a tone of a particular kind of book.
And then it goes into an event.
And the tone of the comic becomes the tone of the event.
And as soon as that event is over,
the tone of the comic goes back to normal again and is kind of jarring.
And so what you end up getting here is,
is initially Jamie Bradick who kind of shoots down the idea and saying like,
Hey, no, I really don't want to have anything to do with,
with basically sneaking in to other world and essentially betraying the rules of
Saturday name laid down. That's not supposed to happen.
And so we're sisters like, look, you know, I, if, if we can,
if we can pull this off,
like we can basically help you kind of preserve your fun. Right. You know,
preserving your fund is what we're shooting for it.
And that's when Jamie's like, Hey, Milford, ah,
take the horse and get the horse out of here, if you can, you know, or,
you know,
because supposedly you're good at horses or that's what you claim and me for.
It's like, I never said that, man. I never said I was good with horses. Right.
And so I was like, dude, I'm getting like Jimmy Biotics, like, dude,
I'm getting tired of hearing that.
Just take the horse and get outta here the whole time.
You first just trying to like pull on this horse.
And then Jamie Bradick in the midst of a conversation with sinister, you know,
we're sitting there kind of references the fact that this place is kind of
unsafe under the rule of Jimmy Bradick. Jimmy's like, Oh man, he's like,
someone's been talking about it's her. And he's like,
Newford I just remember it. It was I who was raised around horses, not you, you.
And there's this guy.
Goofiness, right.
That's kind of goofiness and nonsense that comes with the character of Jamie
Bradick and is awesome.
I love that kind of nonsensical nature of him because as goofy as he is,
he's also incredibly powerful, right? I mean,
the guy's able to work reality potentially on a scale he's just that capable.
And so it's one of these things where the response of Jamie is okay, fine.
Then I will do that. And, and I offer you like my priced horse, right?
I offer you silk, Maine.
What are you going to give me in return as part of this deal that we've struck
as part of this bargain, instead of just like,
we're not going to give you anything. I don't want your horse. And that's when,
when you know, he's like,
he's like a horse is like a huge amount of responsibility. And,
and it's kind of funny because Jimmy stands up and he was like,
everybody listening, you know, the words of sinister have touched me.
The idea of responsibility, responsibility is a very important thing.
And I just remember it that I have the responsibility to report any suspicious
involvement, any suspicious actions or suspicions, uh,
suspicious travelers to Saturday. So if I'm going to maintain responsibility,
it's important that I tell her about what it is that you're doing.
And so ultimately you end up having sinister being like, okay,
we're not going to do, we're not going to take the horse,
but I can give you something else in step. And so sinister loses his Cape.
And here's the thing.
On this surface as an old school, as a, as a long time coming book reader,
there's a part of me that's kind of like sinister would never act this way.
Right. As soon as her super hardcore, but there's another part of me.
That's kind of like, I did this, I like the nonsensical sinister, right.
The one who's just like, I don't really take things seriously anymore.
I just kind of goof off, you know, I'm sort of just kind of a, of a goofy guy.
I kind of enjoy that version of sinister because I've been reading the old
school version of sinister for so long. It's pretty fun.
And so once they actually make their way here or there kind of has that,
you know, supposedly kind of interim station kind of a waystation of sorts, uh,
with Jimmy Bradick and they actually arrive into really kind of other world
itself they're immediately met by,
what's essentially an Envoy of Saturn Dean who basically charges them. Right.
Instead of like, you guys have to stop while you guys are in possession of silk,
Maine, uh,
you guys basically have this horse that belonged to Saturday and herself.
The fact that you,
you have this horse means you stole it because we know the horse has been
stolen. Some crazy naked guy just ran up on the property and took it.
So like we know Jamie Bradick and his nakedness just running onto the,
to the territory of Saturday and, and stealing a horse buck naked, which is,
sounds like the most Jamie Brodick thing that a person could do.
I feel like somebody,
like people are kind of skipping to this video and somebody is going to land on
this part and just be like, what?
Well, that's, that's going to be either.
But it's kind of like, okay, like empath, we need your powers,
manipulate their emotions and turn them into allies. And he's like, no,
I'm good. He's like, I hate all of you guys. Okay.
Hey, everybody here, I hope you die.
And I hope that I hope that like when you die.
And if you guys end up coming back, because remember when you,
whenever you die in other world,
there's no guarantee you'll come back the way that you worked. So it was like,
when you guys come back,
you come back and such a screwed up state that like the entirety of Coca-Cola
will cheer. When I, when I suffocate you,
when I spear you have you're miserable.
I hope that's the way things are like.
I hate you guys. And so in response, like sinister,
like surely there's something that you want, right? Some kind of a favor,
I'll give you anything you want. And he's like,
I want grey Crow as my pet grey Crow flips. Right. He's just like,
not a chance I'm going to cut you in half. Right. And so since she was like,
okay, dude, that's fine. Like, like just whatever, you know.
And so he uses his powers. Grey Crow becomes just totally enamored with empath.
He's like, man, your eyes, both sparkling eyes while you're just a radiant soul,
right.
He absolutely adores empath empath and turn his powers on the Envoy Saturnino
and they basically give sinister and his crew,
whatever it is that they need and just kind of go forward from there.
And it's kind of a crazy thing to see this story where,
where Greg Crow is just kind of falling through the grass and talking about how
great impath is.
It's one of these things where you kind of have to go and read the old mutant
massacre and see how like sadistic his character was in order to really get a
grasp for how funny this is. Old-school coming up.
Fans would probably get a kick out of it. Right?
Like the new guys are kind of like says a thing, you know, it's,
it's interesting, but they all kind of agree as they're making,
making their way through here, they all kind of agree.
This is going to go pretty bad. Right? Like they're all kind of like,
this is going to be, this is like a suicide mission basically. Right? So it's,
it's almost kind of like the hellions have become Marvel suicide squad.
It's kind of wild, but it's like, we're probably going to die.
And if we don't die, we're definitely not going to succeed.
Things are going to go pretty terrible for us. Right.
So they're definitely off to a great start with that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end. If you are new here to come and explain,
make sure you guys at the sub button to become part of the Rob core.
If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a like, and I will.
You all later,
[inaudible].